welcome everyone thank you for coming
out and they're sort of chilly autumn
evening we might burn John if he doesn't
tell us to rate things if I have a
fireplace going so all right so there's
a special lecture it's a part of a two
nights lecture series it's the annual
deulim lecture series named after
stanislav alam the polish american
mathematician who worked on the
Manhattan Project he invented a whole
range of extraordinary techniques
including cellular automata the Monte
Carlo method he suggested nuclear pulse
propulsion which is a intriguing way of
sending rocket ships out into space and
he has many other accomplishments he
also wrote a beautiful book called
adventures of a mathematician and I
think he has a cry of a quote from that
book that seems very fitting for what's
going on in this country over the last
couple of weeks or the world I should
say and he wrote with respect to his
experiences working on the Manhattan
Project sometimes I feel that a more
rational explanation for all that has
happened during my lifetime is that I am
still only 13 years old
reading Jules Verne or HG Wells and have
fallen asleep right time to wake up
let me just recognize I'm Claire and
Steve Reiner who are here tonight and
they're over there somewhere I can't
really see you but Claire is Stan ulam
daughter and so we're just round of
applause for the folks ordinary family
and we're so delighted that the wine has
remain involved with SFI support esse
fine and income to all of our events
thank you to Thornburg investment
management for their support of the
series and of course to the lens Athiya
tur for hosting these lectures so
tonight and tomorrow so if you came
tonight come tomorrow today as an
appetizer tomorrow's the main course if
you prefer today as the main course
tomorrow's the dessert you pick and our
speaker is John gianopolous he is the
James Tobin professor of economics at
Yale and external professor at SFI John
got his BA in mathematics from Yale and
his MA and PhD in economics from Harvard
working with the Nobel laureate Anna
Pharaoh and Jerry Green so at SFI the
social sciences and Natural Sciences
have always coexisted intermingled
conjugated and reproduced and starting
very few years after we were found in
1984 and as early as 1987 and running
for a series of years Ken ro John's
advisor the Nobel laureate working with
another Nobel laureate Phil Anderson
convened a series of meetings at SFI to
apply concepts of evolution to the
creation of a new economic theory and
John sustained that ambition and in 1992
91 and then 99 to 2000 he directed the
economics program at SFI and in fact in
as early as 1991 John was exploring the
role of machine learning and statistical
inference to predicting financial
systems which of course has now come of
age John is in many ways pre adapted to
life identify what does that mean
exactly it means that in 1970 he won the
United States Junior Open Chess
Championship and at SFI we've long had
an interest in combinatorial games of
zero chance a chess and go and so forth
John's dad was also a professor at Yale
and he was actually a professor of
Antron cultural and religious history
wrote many beautiful books and I was
told that when John first got to Yale as
professor in 1980 they would give
lectures in parallel and his dad's
lectures would be attended like this
hundreds of people fawning after him and
and hanging on every word and John would
have about three people in his audience
so he's moved on so I should say that
since the onset of the late 2000
financial crisis John's work on the
relationship between leverage and asset
prices the so-called leverage cycle has
been prominent in both popular and
academic discussions on market
fluctuations and regulation John also
has an applied side like many SFI
affiliated faculty and he was one of the
founding partners in 1995 of Ellington
Capital Management where he remains a
partner don't make a personal note about
John and I hand over to him over the
years John and I have maintained a
collegial and some people might claim
childish debate on the precedents of
evolutionary thought of economic thought
my position or economic thought over
evolutionary thought John's position and
at stake is whether the combination of
Adam Smith and Malthus recognized the
essential role of competition and
resource distribution as a foundational
force for order John claims or whether
they overlooked the evidence stumbled
about the crime scene as most economics
economists are one to do and where it
took the originality and genius of
Darwin to solve the great puzzle of
nature the argument the argument is
futile I'm right
but it does give you a sense of how
these different great intellectual
traditions can begin to be integrated
just in closing just to say that John
was elected a fellow of the economic
Society in 1990 the American Academy of
Arts in science is 99 he won the
Samuelson Prize in 1999 and was a wooded
the first Buddhist a key prize in
economics in 1994 so John take it away
well thank you very much it's David for
introducing me it's a pleasure to be
back here in Santa Fe I never met
Stanislav I didn't see where his
daughter was by the way where is she
oh there you are hello so David reminded
me about chess and Santa Fe and machine
learning and one of my first papers I
wrote in Santa Fe was called when seeing
further isn't seeing better and I
attempted to explain how chess
algorithms worked and basically tried to
show that the computer would never beat
Gary Kasparov and I presented the paper
to Gary Kasparov at lunch just a few
months before he was defeated computer
so the the subject of my talk is dead
and its discontents it's something that
everybody knows about because almost
everybody has been in debt at one point
and thought about lending money or
borrowing money debts plagued multitudes
for millennia it's caught you know
debtors prison it's caused booms and
busts wrecking economies we've created
central banks to manage credit we
created macroeconomics to study these
booms and busts and how the credit was
managed we've had thousands of years of
philosophers talking about debt and what
it means and with all that we couldn't
stop the Great Recession of 2007 so
somehow
after all that the macroeconomic
consensus that had emerged before the
Great Recession needed a little
fine-tuning and so I'm going to present
a proposal to change the macro consensus
and central bank policy and Steven said
it's like call it the leverage cycle and
I'm gonna say that actually it's quite
consistent with what all those
philosophers were talking about all
those thousands of years in fact might
have been they might have anticipated
the whole thing if they had added a
little mathematics to what they were
doing I'm gonna tell you some other
alternative theories from after the
crisis actually the leverage cycle was
from before the crisis and I'm gonna
explain what mathematical economics is
and why it's useful to do mathematics
and economics almost everything that you
hear about debt you can tell a story
about so what's the point in mathematics
well the person who had the greatest
impact on making economics mathematical
not the first but the one with the
greatest impact was Kenneth arrow who my
thesis advisor who David referred to and
the starter as it were of the economics
program so I'm going to explain a little
bit what he did and what how my theory
fits into that and why he didn't think
of it and then then I'm going to in the
next lecture flesh out the leverage
cycle and try to make a little more
practical and try to explain what
happened in the crisis here the Great
Recession in America and what's happened
and still happening in Europe although
both places are getting a little better
now so I probably don't have to remind
you that the Great Recession was pretty
bad this is a picture of of GDP from
1932 actually to last year or the year
before I forgot to update the slide and
you can see that it goes steadily up it
has these little blips downward but
every time it has a little blip downward
I'm starting after the depressions that
was a big blip downward but after that
from 1930 to 2008 seven or eight every
time it went down it quickly recovered
so if you look at how fast it was going
up it blip
down a tiny bit then goes up faster to
catch up to where it would have been
before those were all the recessions we
had before but look at what happened in
2008 there it went down a whole trillion
dollars it had been going up a trillion
dollars the previous few years you know
the slope so you could say GDP was down
two trillion dollars compared to what it
might have been without the Great
Recession and every year after that it
hasn't caught up to where it's been
before it's still parallel to what it's
old trajectory was just a trillion or
two below what it was so you know you
could probably overestimate the cost of
the recession this way but this has been
going on for eight or nine years a
trillion or two trillion dollars less
than what you might imagine it could
have been we might have lost ten or
fifteen trillion dollars in the Great
Recession think of what we could have
done the Iraq war was two or three
trillion we could do a lot with 15
trillion dollars and somehow we didn't
avoid it so it's a mistake that needs to
be rectified it didn't just happen in
America here's an updated picture it's
happened all over Europe so this is GDP
in a bunch of different countries
including Japan in the US and you can
see that all of them Spain is the top
when they started a hundred you know I
normalized it to start at a hundred in
1980 they're all cruising up and then
there's this big crash and almost all of
them they don't improve much the worst
one is Greece that I'm going to be
talking about it hasn't grown at all
since the crash there the others you
know they pick up a little bit but there
they never catch up to where they would
have been before so year after year
after year after year every one of these
countries is losing output losing
potential income that they could have
put to some good use you'll notice by
the way that Germany and Japan they have
a tiny blip down and then they do catch
up to where they were before I'll come
back to that later
so what is the consensus what was the
consensus I'm sure you know it
yourselves you just read the newspapers
and you know what the basic story of
macroeconomics is and what the Federal
Reserve is supposed to do
the basic idea was always emerged you
know from Keynes onward it was worked
over and over again the basic consensus
was well sometimes demand is too high
and sometimes it's too low sometimes
there's too much inflation sometimes
there's too little output and the
Federal Reserve by adjusting the
interest rate when things are too hot it
raises the interest rate if things
aren't going very well that lowers the
interest rate by adjusting the interest
rate it can restore the natural path of
the economy and for a long time it kept
things on a very even keel
now people including Keynes recognize
that if the interest rate were zero
there wouldn't be any room to adjust the
interest rate down and so there's a
little problem with the zero lower bound
which we're of course near now but other
than that it was all about adjusting the
interest rate you read the newspapers
even today after the crisis and they
talk about Janet Yellen what are they
talking about Janet Yellen by the way
was a graduate student at Yale about
four or five years ahead of me and then
also an assistant professor at Harvard
four or five years ahead of me so I
always heard about Janet Yellen I had to
take out one Tobin's course and I had no
idea what was going on for a while and I
got Janet yellen's notes and then it
became clear what was going on anyway
she she if you read the newspapers it's
all about is she gonna raise the
interest rate or not raise the interest
rate or when is she gonna raise the
interest rate is she gonna unwilling
quantitative easing or not on one
quantitative easing that's all about the
long interest rate was designed to keep
the long interest rate low too so
they're still talking about the interest
rate now if you think of economics
macroeconomics is all about the interest
rate what do you mean by tight credit
everybody every business person even
non-business people they talk about
tight credit credits tight tech credits
loose well if you keep if you're serious
about the interest rate you must mean
the interest rates too high of credits
tighter it's too low if interest rate
you know if credit is loose but I don't
think that's what business people mean
when they say credits tight or credits
loose what they mean is at the interest
rate that's currently prevailing credit
is tight when they can't get a loan
and why can't they get a loan because
the lenders think that they might
default so at the interest rate that you
can read in the newspapers they can't
get a loan and then we know interested
is tight so what was missing in the
macroeconomic story was default it just
didn't appear in the story at all so
what I'm going to talk about is the
possibility of default and when you
think of default and very soon you can
think of collateral so the purpose of
collateral is to make the lender feel
more secure about the loan so the bigger
the collateral is the more secure the
lender feels and of course you have to
take the ratio of the collateral to the
loan so that's called leverage so the
loaned value is the loan amount divided
by the collateral amount so for example
you have a hundred dollar house and you
borrow 20 and you start you borrow 80
and you pay $20 of cash you've borrowed
80% of the house the loan to values 80%
the margin or down payment is 20% and
the leverage with $20 you managed to buy
a hundred dollar house it's five times
your cash you got to sort of stretch it
by five times it's all those words the
collateral rate is a hundred divided by
80 is 5/4 they're all different ways of
saying the same thing it's a ratio that
key ratio you can look at at different
ways now one important aspect of
leverage that I think every investor
knows including Shakespeare by the way
is that if you're leveraged five to one
say you have a house you bought with AE
dollars borrowed and put $20 down and
the house goes up by a dollar that's one
percent and you sell the house you have
to pay back the 80 so you end up with
twenty one dollars but you only pay 20
down so basically you've made five
percent on your money so the asset goes
down one dollar then you have 19 left
you lost 5% of your money so leverage
multiplies your risk and that's the way
all business people look at leverage
that's the way economics textbooks
looked at leverage that everybody knows
but beyond that at least when I was a
student they never said anything about
collateral and lever
and I didn't take us even in finance you
wouldn't hear very much about leverage
or collateral
not to mention never in macroeconomics
so I changed the way I thought I mean so
how did I think about leverage well I
decided in 1989 that I wanted to see
what was happening on Wall Street I was
a mathematical economist the most
mathematical things and economics were
being done in finance on Wall Street and
I had I decided to go to a little firm
it's not that little there's a seventh
biggest investment bank at the time
called Kidder Peabody
it wasn't goldman sachs where most
academic economists tried to go because
it was a very academic intellectual
place but I had a little cousin who had
just graduated college and who is that
Kidder Peabody and he introduced me to
the person who ran fixed-income at
Kidder Peabody and that guy said why go
to Goldman Sachs and be one of a hundred
economists you know in a corner working
on some little option pricing problem
come and talk to me and you'll learn a
lot more so I went there and I did learn
more probably than ever at least I was
in the right place it turned out so cute
her Peabody my I was there for a while
and I was reading about mortgages I
didn't really know much about mortgages
at all I didn't realize what went on
behind the scenes I had no idea at the
time that if you get a mortgage the bank
doesn't hold your mortgage it sells it
to somebody and then they package it
into these big pools and they cut the
pools up and stuff like that it's a huge
complex operation actually much more
mathematical than anything else on Wall
Street so I picked exactly the right
spot and I spent a year there and had a
good time talking to this guy and at the
end of the year he said you know I've
learned from you that my research
department isn't very mathematical why
don't you run the research department
from Yale and hire me a new really said
hire me a new research department so I
hired 25 people over the summer before I
went back to Yale but he said okay
you've hired the first 25 run the
department from Yale so I thought my
gosh this might be interesting I didn't
realize what was interesting and also a
little frenzied and a little more drama
the night
but I did it and it turned out that
Kidder Peabody became the center of
mortgages in America and securitization
so my there was a scandal in the
mortgage department and my little cousin
his early 20s got promoted to be the
head of of mortgages collateralized
mortgages and he built it into the
biggest mortgage operation on Wall
Street so we did 20% of all the
mortgages on Wall Street by the time he
was 28 or so he issued half a trillion
something like that dollars of
complicated mortgage derivatives and
Kidder Peabody was just booming along
and as I was seeing all this activity
everything around me was involved
collateral every single deal they made
they'd say all this guy might not pay us
what's the collateral he's putting up
when you get a mortgage you might
remember what happens is you get a
mortgage the bank buys your mortgage so
they feel safe because the house
collateral eise's it then they sell it
into a pool and the pool is split up
into other pieces the pieces are
collateralized by the pool then the
buyers of the complicated pieces they
don't pay for them by cash they borrow
most of the money and use the pieces of
themselves as collateral for what they
buy so there was collateral everywhere
back and forth I couldn't keep track of
how much collateral there was and I'd
never seen it in any economics course so
I decided I should be writing about
collateral equilibrium so that was the
first thing I did at 1997 well after 135
years Kidder Peabody closed it was one
of the early scandals on Wall Street it
was a traitor in the government bond
department name Joe jet some of you were
old enough to remember this and he'd
apparently made a trillion he apparently
made 200 million dollars the year before
but actually it turned out on closer
examination he'd actually lost a hundred
million dollars and so they they fired
him and then he sued them for
discrimination because he was black and
so it was a huge scandal as the front
pages of the newspapers for incredibly
long time
and then suddenly General Electric
decided to close Kidder Peabody and I
had to go back to my office at Kidder
Peabody and invite the 75 people who
worked for me in research and say I'm
sorry you're fired
I'm sorry you're fired the 75th person
left and I went to the office next door
the guy said I'm sorry you're fired and
so we all fired each other 6000 people
got fired in one day and I didn't
realize at the time what had done I'm
wrong but the interest rates had it was
1994 and the interest rates which had
been going steadily down went up eight
times and it was part of a leveraged
cycle but I didn't realize I had no idea
what's going on at the time so we
decided to form my cousin decided to
found this hedge fund called Ellington
and Ellington was going to now buy the
securities that he'd previously been
creating and he you know our model was
we created the mess let us clean it up
and we didn't get too many investors
with that model but but we did make a
lot of money because it was right after
a crash and it turns out that that's the
best time to be an investor something
else I was learning for the first time
so we were booming along at Ellington
and pretty soon we were doing so well
began to attract a lot of investors and
things were going really well and then
one of our competitors was much bigger
and more famous than us awful not bigger
in mortgages but in general name
long-term capital they went out of
business you may heard of them founded
among by 12 people including two Nobel
Prize winners in economics they almost
destroyed the reputation of economics
Nobel Prizes but they went out of
business and we celebrated one of our
best you know competitors going out of
business well a few months later we got
a margin call so that what does that
mean that means on a Tuesday morning we
got caught got Tuesday morning on a
Friday morning we got called before 10
a.m.
and we were told we had to produce a
certain amount of money a margin call
and if we didn't raise the money by four
o'clock then we would our assets would
all be sold that were collateral and of
course if we've borrowed
80 in the assets are worth 100 they only
need 80 they're not gonna sell them
probably as efficiently as we might they
probably only get 80 for them and so
this is a disaster for us and we
couldn't raise the money by the
afternoon and so it was big drama we
thought we're all gonna go out of
business we had all these lawyers come
in and tell us that you know if you lose
all a little bit of money you're a hedge
fund no one cares you lose all the money
you'll be sued for incompetence or worse
than that and they might take your house
and and so so we didn't know what we
were gonna do and then my cousin decided
that we would try to auction these
assets ourselves over the weekend it was
Columbus Day weekend so anyway we ran an
auction we split it into three pieces
and the first piece we auction them off
you know we just told people to bid and
we got all the bids in and they were all
80 and that wasn't good and so my cousin
said we're gonna answer all the emails
and tell everybody they were outbid so
we told everyone they were outbid and
then we auctioned the second third two
hours later and we got all the bids and
they're at 95 and then they're at 99 the
third time so we survived to fight
another day but it was one of the most
frightening experiences that I've been
through and so I thought I mean this is
twice I've been in a place that's nearly
gone out of business and I've thousands
of people the first time and you're not
quite so many the second time could have
been fired and it can't all be my fault
I was in charge of making the models
maybe it was all my fault but I might
say can't all be my fault
there must be something systemic going
on and that's when I tried to think of
the leverage cycle so I presented the
leverage cycle in the 2000 econometrics
Society meetings that's going to tell
you about anyway Ellington boomed after
that near crash because after crisis is
the best time to be an investor it
boomed until the next crash in 2008 in
the 2007 2008 and again we teetered on
the brink although not quite as bad that
time and we survived again almost very
similar story
and I learned something new which was
forgiveness which I hadn't thought of
before
really very carefully and all these
homeowners were defaulting and they were
they were being thrown out of their
houses and the lenders were getting
almost nothing back 20 cents on the
dollar they were getting back if they
forgave the loan they could have done so
much better and so I testified twice in
Congress about forgiveness the 17 hedge
funds wanted to forgive debt like our
hedge fund they asked me to represent
them all but I thought be better to
speak as a Yale professor about
forgiveness
but anyway the 17 of them got someone
else to represent them and said they
wanted to forgive debt and I said it was
the right thing to do and of course we
didn't do it not a single penny of
subprime debt was forgiven but I'm gonna
come back to that story next lecture now
I gave the graduation speech at the
University of Athens economics and
Business School and I talked about
forgiveness and I basically said that
you know we should have forgiving debt
in America and that would have gotten us
out of our crisis the only solution to
the Greek problem is to forgive debt um
I think it's gonna happen because how
could it not happen and your families
you won't have to grow up and leave
Greece like my grandparents did to find
opportunity the debt will be forgiven
and there'll be opportunity again in
Greece so the one of the professor's
there turned out to be later the
Minister of Finance and although I
probably didn't believe a word I was
saying he asked me to help him with the
great debt in the negotiation with the
troika last year so I want to talk about
that as well next time so that's how I
got that's how the idea came to me about
the leverage cycle so what is the
theoretical idea of the leverage cycle
the key idea it's that when people can
leverage more the asset prices go up
it's as simple as that
you know finance was caught in the
throes of efficient markets that every
acid it's priced and you know by a
rational calculation of
dividends it'll pay and the the market
sussed us out what's going on and
figures out the fair price given what
the market knows and what everybody
knows about potential pitfalls and what
the dividends can be but I was saying it
doesn't matter I mean it matters what
the dividends are but beyond that if you
take two assets with the same dividends
but one of them can be leveraged than
the other can't it's gonna sell for a
higher price and similarly if it can't
be leveraged it'll sell for a lower
price and that works not only on the
scale of a single asset but on the scale
of a whole economy and the reason is
very simple that if you the reason it's
very simple that if you point very
slowly the reason is very simple
that if you if you have a bunch of
buyers and you order them according to
who's the most optimistic and who's the
least optimistic somebody's up the price
is going to be equal to somebody's
opinion say the marginal buyer so what
happens if we can leverage more well you
need less people to buy because they can
each get their hands on more money so
the number of buyers the people above
the marginal buyer are the ones who
think the price is good they're gonna be
the buyers the one below the marginal
buyer will be the sellers if people can
leverage more you won't need as many
buyers so that group of buyers can
shrink which means the marginal buyer is
higher but the marginal buyers valuation
is now a higher person and that's the
price so the price has to go up it's as
simple as that and these people who
these people who are can differ for all
kinds of reasons they can be different
risk tolerance they can different
ability to hedge they can just like the
asset differently so some people like a
house and some people don't like houses
they can be more productive on the farms
than other people some people can just
be more optimistic than others there's a
variety of reasons why people would
differ and why you shouldn't expect
everyone to have the same opinion so the
second key idea is that leverage is
going to depend on volatility what could
be more obvious the more dangerous the
world is the more insecure the lenders
are going to feel and the more less
leverage they're gonna permit so the
leverage cycle basically works like this
you start with
of acids and people can borrow say 80%
time goes by where volatility seems very
low the world sees sake seems safe
everything's going well and meanwhile
there are people like my cousin doing
these technologies innovations on Wall
Street to stretch the available
collateral that's what these
collateralized mortgage obligations are
all about stretching the available
collateral use the same house as
collateral many times so with innovation
and people feeling safe the amount you
can borrow goes up don't when the amount
you can borrow goes up the price goes up
and now you can borrow a higher
percentage of a higher number so you can
borrow a huge amount more so here the
world looks wonderful everything's gone
up everybody's feeling safe things only
going up but the economy's at its most
vulnerable because everybody is
stretched so far so when a little piece
of bad news comes and the price goes
down and now maybe it's underwater a
little bit some people are gonna lose
money but who's gonna lose the most
money well it's the leverage buyers and
remember if you're leveraged five to one
you lose five times the fall of a
housing price if you're leveraged thirty
to one you lose 30 times the price of
the housing price so the left the most
ambitious buyers the most opportunistic
optimistic buyers they're the ones who
are leveraged the most they are the ones
who lose all the money so because of
that their demand goes away they're
forced to sell on the price goes down
even more
but now the lenders say to themselves
well the world has changed it's more
dangerous than it was before we're not
gonna lend at that amount that leverage
of ninety five percent or something and
so the new buyers who want to buy maybe
they're not as optimistic as before but
they can't even borrow the money to buy
so the new buyers really are constrained
and the price falls even further so at
that point if the gap gets big enough
the debt is here and the asset values
are here
that's the calamity but it's a double
calamity because you're never gonna get
paid so if you insist on squeezing as
much money as you can out of the
homeowner you're gonna end up with less
than you would otherwise if we gave part
of it and that's the idea of forgiveness
so the Fed what should the Fed do
it should prevent the leverage from
getting so high when it's going way up
and when things are going down and
nobody can borrow the Fed should step in
and make borrowing easier and it should
help with forgiveness that's my basic
theme so it's a Santa Fe theme maybe but
now here's some evidence for it and then
I'm gonna elaborate it a little bit so
it seems to fit the data pretty well so
what I have here is a chart that
Ellington used to keep before anybody
was thinking about collateral and we
were and the blue line is the loan to
value that we had to pay or would have
had to pay the maximum loan-to-value we
could get on a basket of securities that
we were typically interested in buying
not that we would leverage that much but
that's what they would allow us to
leverage so you see it's at 90 on the
left-hand side and then it suddenly
drops to 60 that was the 98 crisis I I
told you about which is me what made me
think about the leverage cycle but that
blip came back very quickly in a few
months everybody said that the lenders
were just panicked and crazy for setting
you know changing margins so drastically
and we thought and anyway but I thought
maybe they weren't so crazy maybe the
world just that happens every now and
then margins suddenly change so you can
see that margins are adjusting now the
red is the price of these securities
these are bonds that are floating and so
the price doesn't need to change unless
you're afraid it's going to default so
you can see that leverage goes up there
in in 95 or so it goes up to 95 percent
twenty times leverage and then it starts
to drop everybody gets a little scared
about the uncertainty and look at what
happens to the asset prices they say
plummet just with leverage and then they
both go up together so it's a remarkable
fit but of course it's really only two
or three points because everything else
you know but it's seen it's quite an
astonishing parallel so then let's take
another example the housing prices so
the blue line or the Green Line is
housing prices starting in 2000 it's the
Case Shiller index and as Shiller was
fond of pointing out housing prices went
from a hundred to one hundred ninety
ninety percent in this
index in in until 2006 that's where it
hits its peak 90% in six years it's it's
incredible it's almost unheard of he
said it's crazy
these people are irrationally exuberant
they must be telling each other things
can't do anything but go up and you know
and so it's and so he actually predicted
that things had to turn around because
things had just gone up too high said
they were crazy well they probably were
crazy some of these homeowners but they
weren't completely crazy because if you
look at the loan-to-value so these are
all the non government loans of which
there were half were non government
loans in this period and it's the
average loan devalue or a down payment
I've written as down payment that the 50
percentile guys put down so in 2000 was
14% in the same quarter that housing
reaches its peak the down payment goes
to 2.7 percent so you went to almost 40
times leveraged from seven times
leveraged and then you see that leverage
collapses I'll explain why next tomorrow
and then you see that the you see that
the housing prices collapsed - so
Shiller would say the housing prices
collapsed because the narrative changed
people started saying oh I can't keep
going up forever something must be going
wrong and so people said we better sell
before everyone else sells I'm saying
something was going wrong and it was
very hard for a new buyer to get a loan
okay so take just a little bit more
evidence so here is the loan devalue or
the debt to income debt household debt
to income in a bunch of different
countries in 97 and 2007 so you see
Italy goes up a lot you see Spain in the
middle goes up a lot you see you see
Ireland on the end goes up a tremendous
amount in Norway up which and the u.s.
goes up in England goes up you know from
the gray to the to the red but you see
in the middle Japan it's actually gone
down in Germany next to it it's even
gone down a little bit and then you see
what happened to the you have leverage
on the horizontal axis who you know
whose leverage went up the most in the
vertical axis you see whose housing
prices went up the most
there it is Ireland at the top UK Spain
Norway all those countries Denmark we
said and there at the left no leverage
no increasing housing prices Germany in
Japan they didn't ask what happened
after the crisis who lost the most well
Germany and Japan lost the least at the
top left and there you are with Ireland
and Spain at the bottom right okay now
another idea that's going to emerge in
the leverage cycle is the credit surface
so if you ask how much interest you have
to pay depending on how what your loan
to value is it's a very small loan to
value the lenders are gonna feel
perfectly safe and you're gonna pay sort
of the riskless interest rate the
loan-to-value starts to go up the
interest rate is eventually going to
start to go up and go up quite sharply
so this picture answers the puzzle what
does it mean for tight crib
what does it mean that credit is tight
doesn't mean that the interest rate at
the riskless one is too high it means
that the it goes up too fast it's too
steep the most interesting borrowers
probably the ones who are you know might
default and so they're gonna pay a high
interest rate and so their interest rate
might be going up a lot even if they're
in Ch riskless interest rate isn't going
up at all so that's the definition of
tight credit a steep credit surface so
this is not anything a practitioner
wouldn't be aware of or think of it's
just that somehow it isn't pictorially
captured so I got a graduate student to
do the credit surface in 2013 of all the
Fannie and Freddie loans so on the Left
axis you see LTV so on the back it's a
hundred in the front as low LTVs on the
right is something else that's gonna
play a role it's called FICO or credit
score it's true in corporates you know
in individuals you might know your own
credit scores it's actually shocking how
low they can be if you're just a little
bit late paying things but anyway the
credit score on the right is eight
hundred in the near-term that's a very
good credit score it can even be
slightly higher than that and it goes
down to 650 in the back but look at the
interest rate so these are the best
borrowers in America they're Fannie Mae
freddiemac conforming you know borrowers
who were allowed to enter those programs
this is middle America and even for them
the interest rate goes from 3.8 percent
for the good people in the in the near
term all the way up to 4.6 in the bad
term so that I think captures the credit
situation in the economy and is we're
gonna see tomorrow that curve can be
that surface can be very steep or very
flat when it's steep it means credit is
tight when it's flat it means credit is
loose and it can be a different picture
depending on what the collateral is so
there's there should be a well I'm going
to show you there's a corporate credit
surface and a mortgage credit surface
and a consumer loan credit surface and
if we could keep track of those if the
Fed would be producing these every
quarter like my student did the Fed is
now working on this we would have a much
better picture of what's going on in
credit and and and what the central bank
should do so the leverage cycle as I
said when things are getting better and
volatilities going down credit standards
loosen that pushes things up and gets
everything going better again and you
keep going round and round where things
get better and better but then something
bad happens and you start going round
and round in the other direction so okay
so my recommendation that you're gonna
see tomorrow is that we should be
keeping track of these credit services
and the Fed what it's deciding what to
do should have in mind if we lower the
rate we're gonna move the credit surface
down maybe not even in parallel and
we're gonna move the corporate credit
surface and not the mortgage credit
surface and which one do we want to move
quantitative easing they bought
mortgages they didn't buy corporates so
anyway so that that's gonna leave that
for tomorrow okay so that was my idea
which I want to elaborate but I want to
tell you now a little bit about the
history of this so I'm gonna first
mentioned Shakespeare so Merchant of
Venice that you've all heard of and
you're of an age where you might have
read it although the young people today
they apparently it's not regarded as one
of Shakespeare's great plays anymore so
it's not read so much but in my youth
everybody read it it was
garden is one of his great plays and was
supposed to be a comedy and a love story
but actually he was about the leverage
cycle so so the play opens many of
Shakespeare's blades open with him
telling you what the play is about so it
opens with the Merchant of Venice
Antonio going on stage and he says
forsooth I don't know why I'm so sad I'm
so melancholy and the other guy says
well you know it's obvious you you
you've got all your boats on the oceans
and you know this is so risky you must
be scared to death and he says now every
boats on a different ocean I'm not
worried at all that's not it and then
the guy says well you must be worried
about love and he says no I'm not
worried about love so you see
Shakespeare's announced at the very
beginning that although people think
it's a love story in a comedy it's
really about business first and love
second and not only that but he
understands diversification so so what
happens in the play the the Bassanio the
hero of the play he wants to marry the
rich Portia we find out she's rich
before we find out she's beautiful which
of course she also is wants to marry a
Porsche but she can't he doesn't have
the money to go woo her so he needs to
borrow it and Antonia doesn't have any
money cuz it's all tied up in his boats
so they have to go to Shylock the Jewish
moneylender who's willing to lend the
money and they have this tremendous
debate about what the rate of interest
should be and Shylock Antonio says
basically you you know if you were
Christian you would understand you
shouldn't charge interest and it's just
terrible that you want to charge
interest and Shylock explains what
basically is today the modern theory of
impatience theory of interest which is
childlike says you're impatient you
really need the money in a hurry I'm
willing to wait that's why you need the
money for me now and that's why you're
willing to pay interest and so you know
I'm willing to give it to you if you pay
me enough interest so they go back and
forth biblical references and stuff five
pages about what the rate of interest
should be
then they negotiate the collateral now I
saw The Merchant of Venice with
what's-his-name on Broadway
Al Pacino thank you and I walked out
with a whole bunch of people in the
audience and I said can you tell me what
the rate of interest was that Shylock
charged in the Merchant of Venice
not a single person whom they just seen
the play they couldn't tell me I don't
know if you could tell me what does
you've probably read it not a single
person could tell me
Shakespeare realized the rate of
interest isn't the key variable here
it's the collateral and everybody can
remember the pound of flesh collateral
he made it more dramatic because it's
more important so he understood it was
about the leverage cycle so what happens
what happens to the loan is that the
boats apparently of Antonio have all
sunk and so now they're not going to be
able to pay back the loan and so Shylock
makes the margin call he says I want my
money they say why don't you just wait
for the boats he said I want my money
he's promised me the money I you know
I'm old the money and so they have a
trial and Portia who's so rich who's by
this time married Bassanio she's so rich
she makes a deal with the judge maybe
pays him off that and disguises herself
as the judge so she says Shylock can't
you be generous can't you so show mercy
and Shylock says Mercy's irrelevant here
we made a deal was a contract was freely
agreed on venice has to enforce
contracts that's what make commerce run
if you don't enforce this contract
you're going to destroy the city and she
says well you're very right Shylock that
commerce does depend on enforcing
contracts but sometimes contra it's so
important that you change that it's
possible for the judge to intervene so
the court intervenes and change is not
the interest rate or the loan amount or
anything like that she changes the
collateral it was a pound of flesh but
not a drop of blood they didn't say not
a drop of law it was clear what they
agreed she adds but not a drop of blood
and once they've changed the collateral
he can't get his pound of flesh and so
he doesn't end up getting his money
and so Bassanio rushes up and says old
noble judge
you're so wonderful can I reward you for
that great judgement she said I don't
need a reward he said oh please let me
reward you and she says when you see
that ring you're wearing I'd like that
it's no no no no I just got married to
the fair Portia and and she gave me her
ring and I promised I'd never give it up
so until I died I can't give you that
ring and she says is it important for
you to reward me or not did you say he
wanted to reward me I want the ring and
so he gives her the ring and so he's
supposed to be a complete fool and I
went to Harold Bloom yells greatest
Shakespeare scholar and heard his
lecture on on the Merchant of Venice and
he said Bassanio is not going to last
six weeks with Portia once they're
married but in fact he there's another
scene where he sees Portia and you know
she makes him embarrassed ISM asked him
where the ring is and stuff and finally
he confesses all and she forgives him of
course she forgives him what else could
he do
something unexpected happened something
incredibly important happened he decided
he had to break his promise and he did
okay so he's also Shakespeare's
anticipated the forgiveness now what
else did all these people say for a
thousand years all of it was all of it
was about the same things I'm talking
about so if and what are the things I'm
talking about when you talk about debt
you have to talk about the fault you
have to talk about punishment you have
to talk about collateral you have to
talk about restraining borrowing and
that's what all these philosophers were
talking about so we have the Code of
Hammurabi and in that code it was
written on written on on what he call it
what's it called no slate there was
slate it was slate and there was mark
you know how much everybody owed
everybody and there was also those a
slate were we've got the slate tablets
of what was owed we've also got the code
that says if you don't pay what happens
terrible things can happen you can be
enslaved your children can be enslaved
etc so brave punishment for defaulting
so
but also in the code it says if you
agree to an explicit collateral like
your house then they can't enslave you
if you don't default if you default they
just take your house and not only that
Hammurabi like several of his
predecessors he forgave the debt there
were so many people and so much debt
that it was important to forgive it and
they all started with a clean slate
that's where the expression comes from
as you probably know so the Greek drakul
the first person to write down the laws
of Greece said if you default on a loan
you'll be killed
and/or put into slavery sorry we put
into slavery few other things you could
be killed for so these were draconian
punishments he said well you know
they're draconian but that's what they
deserve if I could think of a worse
punishment than murder I've been killing
them I do that but since I can't think
of anything worse so they're all so so
that's where we get the word draconian
from well he was succeeded eventually by
Solon the lawgiver one of the seven
sages of Athens and one of his had lots
of pithy sayings one of them was that
the best in life is to grow old forever
learning new things just before he died
he memorized a new poem because he
wanted to know it wouldn't carry it with
him so he repealed Rocco's laws
including the plate the enslavement for
default and he allowed people to use
their farms as collateral which Drago
had forbidden he also decreed a debt
forgiveness and he had discussed this
with five of his friends who immediately
went out and took big loans and then he
announced of debt forgiveness so they
knew about moral hazard back then too so
Plato's in the Republic which is a book
about justice his first definition of
justice is keeping promises and what
does he discover what is what so that's
what they propose and Socrates debunks
it he says we can't always keep your
promise maybe the person you're supposed
to you know maybe things have changed
something unexpected happened you might
have borrowed a knife from someone when
it comes time to return the knife the
guy might be crazy you shouldn't return
the knife in that case so keeping
promises can't be an ironclad rule of
justice Aristotle by the way thought
interest was barren
you you get that you produce something
out of nothing and it's not natural and
so no interest should ever be charged so
the Romans I gotta move quickly here the
Romans also enslave people and they also
had to forgive them every now and then
to raise an army if there are too many
people and too much in debt they
couldn't raise an army so they had to
forgive them and Caesar himself promised
to forgive the debts of his soldiers
they fought with against Pompey the
Egyptians had the same kind of they
banned enslavement and the rosetta stone
now all of you probably know of the
rosetta stone it's the most visited
object in any museum in the world more
people visit the rosetta stone and visit
anything else in London so the Rosetta
Stone has so famous because it's got
hieroglyphics demotic Egyptian in Greek
and since we know Greek we're able to
decipher hieroglyphics and demonic
Egyptian by having the rosetta stone
that's why it's so famous but when
nobody seems to ask what was so
important that they had to write it in
three languages well it was forgiving
debt ptolemy v was forgiving dead
so people were setting interest rates
left and right you know did I did
everybody knew debt could lead to
trouble
in Judaism they were safe they they had
the seven years forgiving of debts the
fifty year Jubilee a frigate of
returning you know everything freedom
property everything in fifty years and
they had laws about not not lending you
know for to quote Leviticus if your
brother becomes poor take no interest
from him in deuteronomy thou shalt not
lend on usury to thy brother usury of
money usury Victor's usually if anything
of this length upon usury usually is
interest unto a foreigner that macemail
end on usury but not to a brother ok
Christianity st. basil said interest was
terrible and people being in debt you
know they ended up in jail and lost
their children was a horrible thing and
so in the Council of 325 AD they forbade
lending at interest in 1197 it was
called a it was a declared a mortal sin
Islam forbids lending at interest so
everyone's realized there's a
so of course everyone did lend it
interest even though it was forbidden it
happened all the time
Luther thought interest was terrible but
he had a change of heart in 1524 and
Calvin said you know maybe blending it
interest if it's low enough isn't such a
bad thing after all
so in 1545 Henry the eighth legalized
lending at interest just at the time of
Calvin but set a maximum of 10% they
went back and forth ended up getting
lowered to 6% but all this what debtors
prison was emerging and you probably
know that there are several famous
people who've gone writers who've gone
to debtors prison Daniel Defoe wrote
Robinson Crusoe owed 17,000 pounds and
went to debtors prison and this was in
1692 and he managed to get out after a
year because his creditors figured he
might be able to pay them if they let
him out the father of Charles Dickens
John Dickens also went to debtors prison
he got out in three months just changed
Dickens life and he writes constantly
without debt and debtors prison and
David Copperfield is almost about the
story but John Dickens actually got out
after three months because his mother
died and left him a big inheritance so
he could pay his debts but never Daniel
Defoe crusaded against debtors prison
Nietzsche in the genealogy of morals
said actually conscience grew out of
debt conscience and debt are the same
word shoeld at least an archaic word for
conscience and and so what happens he
said after thousands of years of being
horribly punished for not paying your
debts people began to feel bad about not
paying them they developed a conscience
to protect themselves their conscience
wouldn't let them not pay back then they
wouldn't be boiled in oil
in fact people even got to like seeing
people punished for not paying back so
I'm gonna come back to this when we talk
about Greece and so anyway I won't go on
till the Bank of England banks were
created in order to manage interest and
prevent calamities that are arisen but
in all these cases you see people are
talking about the same things that I
said and
everybody had these usury laws that
gradually disappeared in the US the
states had them and what happened there
was a huge in there was a Supreme Court
ruling in 1978 that a bank that opened
in a different state could charge
interest of the new state if the bank
was located in state a it could lend to
the state be using A's interest limit so
therefore you could go to some state
like Minnesota that were at Wisconsin I
forgot which one it was that charged you
know how to had a high debt limit and or
interest limit and he could open
branches everywhere else charging high
interest so this made the states compete
against each other and so it sort of did
away with the usury laws and then there
was a huge inflation in the late 70s and
80s and that made them many of the
states raised their usury laws okay so
I'm going to come back now to the
leverage cycle but I want to mention
some alternatives so what do people say
after the crisis now I develop this
theory before the crisis I think a lot
of people have come to believe in the
leverage cycle maybe they came to it
independently of me too I think there's
some sense to it but it's not like it's
the only theory out there and I want you
to give I want you to be aware of other
alternatives so one of them is held by
many people Kindleberger it was the most
sophisticated it was an MIT professor
who had many anecdotes and basically
what he said is what happens in these
booms and bosses there's some
opportunity something gets invented
there's some reason why people think the
time is different and there's now a
great opportunity there hasn't been for
years so the prices of things start to
go up now they start selling the stuff
and misleading people about what they're
really buying so they're swindling them
to on top of that when the prices are
going up so much people figure I better
get on the bandwagon so I could buy and
you know I can make money too
and on top of that Kindleberger said it
seems curious but every time this
happens it's very eat the interest rates
are low and it seems to be easy to
borrow money so then what happens is
people realized that the opportunity
wasn't so great after all and they all
realized they're wrong and the thing
crashes so then Minsky he had he was
before Kindleberger
he had a theory that a little bit to do
with leverage he said that there are
three kinds of borrowers there are
people who borrow business people borrow
and everything they have to repay they
can repay out of the profits they make
every year then he said when people get
a little bit more speculative they
borrow the interest they can pay out of
their profits but the principal they
can't repay so they have to count on
rolling over the debt they have to count
on profits persisting for a long time so
they can keep rolling over the debt and
then they get really optimistic and they
start borrowing so much that even you
know if the current profits even if they
went on forever they'd never be able to
pay off the debt so as people get more
and more diluted they move from what we
call the hedge borrower to a ponzi
borrower and then one day they all wake
up and they say all this was a drastic
mistake we're all wrong there's really
they can't pay this off and so the price
of the firm's not going to go up so
we'll never be able to pay the debt and
everything collapses okay so that's
similar to Kindleberger a little bit now
there's one other theory and this is the
one that's held by everyone in power and
it starts with a bank run theory so the
explanation of bank runs I think is very
believable you you have the depositors
in a bank and they all think to
themselves you know if I take my money
out does the bank have enough assets to
pay me and they have to not only worry
about pay me but about pay everyone else
because suppose that the assets that the
bank holds maybe in the long run they're
worth a lot but if they had to sell them
very quickly they wouldn't be worth very
much so somebody might say a panic
Weyden's arise because someone will say
you know I think of a long when the bank
is fine but in the short run all these
other guys are gonna take their money
out the bank will be selling things off
to pay them pretty soon there'll be
nothing left for me so I better to ask
for my money too then they all asked for
their money and then the bank really
isn't a terrible fix it has to sell
stuff and can't pay them back so that
story of multiple equilibria if
everybody is patient they'll be plenty
there in the end but if they think the
others are going to take their money out
they have to run to that idea of
multiple equilibria that's the basis of
the sort of banking lender of last
resort because if you can step
and lend to the bank or by the bank's
assets you can stop the panic and save
the bank and that's what central banks
are supposed to do so it's a multiple
equilibrium story but another way of
saying that is you have to restore
confidence and that's what all our rule
or that's what everyone in power always
seems to think so Geithner who is the
secretary of the Treasury during the
crisis he wrote a book called stress
test well that's the title of his book
what did he mean by that
he invented the stress test which was
meant to show in a stress situation with
the bank survive and once the bank's
passed those tests everyone was assured
that the banks were fine
of course the tests in my opinion were
doctored in such a way that the banks
were gonna pass but anyway the stress
test was what made gave confidence to
everybody Bernanke's book head of the
Fed courage to act so again to restore
confidence so it's they think there's a
multiple equilibria if they can just
assure everybody nothing's gonna go
wrong the panic will stop and everything
will stop everything will be okay so
they had to do all sorts of things by
all kinds of stuff to restore confidence
so my story I think there's some truth
to all those stories Kindleberger Minsky
and this bank runs story you know we
have Deposit Insurance
there really isn't runs on banks anymore
they must be talking about runs on in
America there is in Europe runs on banks
but not in America they must have been
talking about runs on money markets and
stuff like that but they got a little
confused I think because they started
talking about runs on collateral the
difference between collateral and a bank
is it's your own collateral it's my you
know I'm a lender that one house is my
collateral if I think that house the
long run is going to be worth plenty of
money there's no reason why I should
panic now no one else can take that
house away from me it's not gonna
disappear
maybe the housing prices are falling but
eventually that house is gonna have a
good value there's no reason why I
should panic so the bank run story
depends on this first-come first-serve
and everybody's trying to get into the
same pot that's not true with collateral
anyway lots of people around
time I started writing about collateral
including Bernanke also started writing
about collateral so not the only person
who wrote about collateral in 97 but the
others didn't write about leverage the
changing leverage which was the key
thing okay so what I want to move to now
is explain the mathematics of the
leverage cycle and I seem to be running
out of time so I'm going to spend I
guess five or ten minutes on this and
then I'm going to have to leave it till
next time and rethink what I'm gonna say
this is gonna be the main part of the
talk so today so you might ask the
question how is it that mathematics is
helpful at all in economics why
shouldn't it be helpful in every social
science why just in economics well one
obvious answer is that there are these
easily measurable things price and
quantity and not only that you can
multiply them together so there's an up
mathematical operation at the basis of
it now when did economics start to
become mathematical it was because of a
financial crisis so in 1929 there was
the stock market crash and there was a
guy named Alfred Coles and he was part
of a very wealthy and famous Cole's
family they were in media and his job
and the media empire was to run a
macroeconomics forecasting company so
every week it would say buy these four
stocks he every week he had four stocks
that people were supposed to buy and the
day before the crash he also told people
they should buy a bunch of stocks and he
was very embarrassed that he hadn't
noticed anything about the crash and so
he went around and read every other
forecasting thing and they all were the
same they were just as bad as he was so
he decided it was all fraud economics
was a complete fraud and it should
become mathematical and so he went to
his father and they decided to start a
mathematics Institute but they didn't
know how to do it so they went to Irving
Fisher who was his Yale professor Alfred
colza Yale undergraduate and asked him
what to do and Irving Fisher said yes
you should start an institute but we
also should start a society we'll call
it the econometrics Society
we should start most famous society in
economics now we should start a journal
we'll call it econometrics it's the most
famous journal in economics now and we
should start a commission the Coles
Commission where people who do
mathematics can come to do economics so
it was like it's interdisciplinary in
mathematical it's like the Santa Fe
Institute you might say and so one of
the most important members of the Cowles
foundation was Kenneth arrow and he's
there in the middle so there he was last
year in November and at Columbia
University and he came because I was
giving the Coles not the Coles the arrow
lecturer at Columbia we've done a
graduate student and he's there with his
to his right is a classmate of mine taka
tae Joos one of Japan's most famous
economists and he also happened to be
visiting New York so he came to the talk
to so this was just before arrow died I
had no idea was so sick he was the
discussant of my talk he and Stiglitz he
gave a brilliant discussion at 95 and
then a couple months later he died so I
thought it would be an interesting thing
to talk about what it is that arrow did
and so I'm gonna spend five minutes
talking about what he did and then I
guess I'll have to stop because this was
going to lead to what I did but well
I'll save that for next time
so what did arrow do how did he make
economics mathematical in a way that
hadn't been done before well you could
imagine people in this theater trading
for goods those are the four goods
sitting there and you each might own
various amounts of those four Goods
apples and oranges and pears therefore
fruit you like fruit differently so as
Apple's might want pears instead so how
what would happen if you traded well you
might scream out offers back and forth
and all pandemonium would break loose so
someone in 1874 called Vaughn Ross he
said equilibrium will arise general
equilibrium there'll be
method to what's going on and even
though everyone's screaming and yelling
at each other and it looks so confusing
in the end can all be described very
simply as part of general
Librium so what is general equilibrium
well this reminds me of a similar
question what is a Nash equilibrium
which is very closely related and I I
after you may have seen the movie A
Beautiful Mind by John Nash what about
John Nash great mathematician and one of
the creators of game theory and so right
after the movie they decided wouldn't it
be wonderful to open the Indian game
theory society and have John Nash be the
featured speaker and so and they invited
a few other people like me to come and
speak as well so in fact thousands of
people came to hear Nash and basically
left before any of the other speakers
could talk and afterwards Nash was with
his wife too we went on tour of India
and every city we went to there was a
news conference you know with reporters
and the first one we went to a reporter
says could each of you speakers could
you say in a word what is game theory
what is Nash equilibrium so everybody
tried to give a definition of Nash
equilibrium me and Nash and the last
person to speak it so happened was this
guy named Robert almond and an Israeli
game theorist and he said that reminds
me of when Nikita Khrushchev gave his
first press conference the old premier
of the Soviet Union in the 1960s his
first press conference open to
Westerners and so one said mr.
Khrushchev can you say and describe in a
word the health of the Russian economy
and he said good and the reporter said
okay take two words and tell us about
the health of the Russian economy
he said not good and so Alan said Nash
equilibrium in one word is interaction
in two words rational interaction so
that's what equilibrium is and what
happens as prices emerge so in
equilibrium
even everyone's screaming about the
prices it's as if everybody knew the
prices in advance it's just the price of
everything somehow magically gets set
and people buy and sell all they can at
those prices where they sell what they
have and
by what they want given that they only
have income from what they sold that's
the definition of equilibrium in Adam
Smith described you know the economy
with the invisible hand that people
without any desire to make things better
you know they're just pursuing their own
selfish interest they make things as
better than they would if they tried so
alright so taking me longer than I
thought so how do you make all that
mathematical that's what arrow did he
made that mathematical and so simple and
he basically showed that the first thing
he showed was that if you look at the
trading that happens when everybody
trades look at their final allocation
you call it Pareto optimal if there's no
way to make everybody better off and
then he proved that in equilibrium the
final allocation will be Pareto optimal
the market somehow will discover the
right way to allocate things distribute
things so that it couldn't be improved
even if you were the central plan or a
new everything and his proof is just a
few sentences they don't have time to
give people had tried for years to
explain it
and pages and pages of mathematics and
he did it and that's the whole proof
that's the whole proof okay if there's
another allocation that makes everybody
better off each person must think that
new allocation was more expensive than
the one than what he ended up with
otherwise he wouldn't have chosen what
he did but if everybody is if this new
allocation cost more for everybody then
it couldn't be feasible because the
total cost of it is more than the total
cost of what's there in the economy so
it wasn't feasible the supposedly better
allocation that's it and then the last
thing he did the second thing he did
that was quite stunning was he said this
equilibrium exists so so lots of people
tried to do this the first guy Varis who
described the equilibria he said look at
my Librium as if they're el commodities
you just look at demand equals supply
for el commodities and if you start with
the wrong prices there's too much demand
and one good you raise that price if
there's too little demand another one
lower that price you'll get to an
equilibrium
well that's no proof of anything
there are many equations that don't have
solutions you can move around however
you want you don't get to a solution but
the economic equations always do have a
solution and Vaughn knowing involved
lots of famous mathematicians were
unable to prove it because they didn't
quite get the details right an arrow de
Bruin McKenzie three people
simultaneously did prove it and so
anyway those are the two things he did
and he started so it's so the economic
system works well but if it works so
well how do you get crashes in finance
what's going on
so arrow also pointed the way to how to
do finance and how and and study so many
more things and he did it with a sleight
of hand okay the last thing I'm gonna
say so if you've got time there was no
time finance is all about time so
suppose you've got pot commodities today
in commodities tomorrow there are two
sets of markets were trading today and
then we're gonna trade tomorrow
well arrow said why not trade all at the
same time now you've just got more eight
commodities instead of four in the same
prices it's like trading an apple today
for an apple tomorrow and then people
said so you don't have to change
anything the market if you could trade
all those things would do perfectly well
and in fact trading an apple today for
an apple tomorrow the relative prices of
those is like the interest rate how many
apples today do I give up if I give a
point Apple today how many apples do I
get tomorrow that's just what the
interest rates like so trading
commodities it's just like finding out
the interest rate
okay this was actually already thought
of by Hickson Irving Fisher himself but
then arrow took one more step and he
said how do you put in uncertainty
before him everybody thought of
uncertainty was normally distributed
variables very complicated stuff and he
said well it's much simpler than that
think of an apple in New York on January
1st 1953 as a different commodity from
the same Apple in New York in 1953
depending on the weather in Paris so you
now have many states of the world so how
does this capture what's going on in the
world well you don't know
what's gonna happen tomorrow many
different things can happen you can
describe a stock now as something you
can describe a stock now these yellow
things or stocks as its payment in each
of the different states and you can
define an insurance contract as what it
pays in the different states so all
these things stocks and insurance
contracts they're like basket of fruits
if you could trade all these goods just
like you were trading the fruit before
an insurance contract or stock is
nothing other than a basket of fruits if
you know what each of the fruits are
worth you know what the stock is worth
or what the insurance contract is worth
so as long as you can trade all the
goods that's the ideal world then the
markets gonna solve every problem and
you'll be able to price all the assets
and price it by figuring out what the
price of those single fruits are the
arrow securities they're called so
though that invention is you know
finance people after that started
talking about state prices you know the
prices of payoffs in every state that
gives you the prices of the assets they
talked about spanning once you have the
prices of all these individual fruits
they add up to the basket of fruit so
that's that you can price the basket and
there's no arbitrage all the words of
Finance came out of that but the key
problem was that he assumed you could
trade all the commodities at time zero
what if you can't trade all the
commodities there are only a few number
of stocks you can trade okay so that
well that was where he stopped and where
I'm going to pick up and I want it okay
so I was going to explain where all this
where all my concepts the credit service
and stuff came from and so I mean I'll
try to do that and abbreviated form next
time but what I'm gonna do next time is
I'm going to give a very abbreviated
form of how I thought of the theory and
how it relates to this simple framework
so you can see where the credit surface
came from and all that and then I'm
going to describe what happened in
Europe and America and try to show that
it conforms to the leverage cycle and
that we did all the wrong things we
could have done so much better than we
did do I mean we've come out of things
now pretty well but it's been almost a
decade later we wasted so much time that
we could have
done better so that's what I want to
talk about next time so I'll stop here
so I'm happy to take a couple questions
okay I have one over here so it is
Pareto work when monopolies manipulate
the prices oh you're asking sorry
thoughts I didn't hear the question does
Pareto work when manipulate monopolies
manipulate prices and market no so the
question was in in this in this world of
being able to trade every potential
contingent commodity you know that's the
idealized world where all risks can be
traded
what happens if they're monopolies
well that causes a problem so you have
to have a lot of competition in order to
get to the idealized world and you have
to have this ability to write every
insurance contract trade every state
contingent commodity and the question is
going to be not so I'm not going to ask
the question what happens with monopoly
I am going to ask the question what
happens when you can't trade every state
contingent commodity yes yes yes right
so you're anticipating when I'm going to
talk about tomorrow of course oh okay
well she's asking so I drew up its - oh
you're back okay so let me just go back
to that credit surface this is what
tomorrow's talk is gonna be about
thank you here it is okay so this says
depending on the FICO and the LTV what
rate you have to pay and you could do
this credit surface for corporates or
for high-yield and and the questioner is
saying you know volatility is low that
means it's pretty safe
so she's guessing that this credit
surface must be quite flat which it is
and that these corporations because it's
so flat or borrowing like crazy and
isn't that a little analogous to what I
was saying about what could possibly go
wrong and so yes I am saying that a
little bit but conditions are much
better than they were in 2007 because
there are lots of the rest of the
economy like the banks and the household
sector that's not very leveraged
compared to what well but so we'll
describe all that tomorrow so I'm not
anticipating an immediate collapse but I
am a little worried and and yeah things
are getting a little so when things look
the best that's when you should be the
worried the most so that's that's the
okay John over here yes sorry I just I
have a question about forgiveness for
example in 2009-2010 yes when there was
a change of covered in Greece and they
find out that Greece had cooked the
books and they'd also cook the books key
in the EU in the first place yes would
have been smart for the EU just to say
Greece we will absorb your debt we kick
you out of the club you're on your own
you can reapply later would have been
much better off just to forgive them
it's very early and dismiss them from
the group then come back and later it
would have been cheaper and we'd had a
lot less trouble today well that was
what many people recommended so the
crowd repeats the question he said
Greece where I'm going to talk about
this tomorrow
but Greece and marie's suddenly
Papandreou announced that the deficit
was really much bigger than it had been
said and that had been misstated and by
the way I'm going to add a little tidbit
which you probably know but it makes for
a good story which I would have told
tomorrow the guy who
the head of the Bureau of Statistics in
Greece who restated the debt was born in
Greece but came to America to go to
Amherst College like Papandreou by the
way who went to Amherst College and we
went to Amherst College and stayed in
America till he was in fifth about this
early 50s
worked at the IMF and saw an
advertisement in Greece for the head of
the Bureau statistics and he didn't know
anything about Greece but he thought he
was qualified so he applied and they
gave him the job and so he restated the
deficit and then he you know I made it
correct and then he said you know if
they botched that deficit probably the
year before they didn't get right either
and he went back and examined that one
and restated that one and of course that
one was wrong too he went back 20 years
and kept restating all the deficits and
made them correct and last year the head
of Parliament in Greece accused him of
crimes against the nation and and he was
in G dire jeopardy of being jailed so
with that background the question was
when Greece had been revealed to have
misstated its debt wouldn't have been
better to forgive Greece's debt and let
them leave the EU and forgiving the debt
right at the beginning certainly would
have made things much better off for
Greece and for the rest of the EU a lot
of the problems wouldn't have happened
so a question is is kicking them out of
a EU you know you probably you mean I'm
not sure how far out of you you mean
they're different stages of what you
could mean by that but the Greeks would
have regarded that as a calamity and so
I'm not sure that that was such
draconian measures were absolutely
necessary to kick them out of the EU so
I would have forgiven the debt that's
what I'm gonna talk about tomorrow and I
would have thought about whether there's
some other way of making them feel I
mean another thing you could do is you
could somehow guarantee everything so
you would protect the rest of the EU let
grief suffer and now that Greece is
suffered enough then forgive the debt so
the question is is how bad do you think
taking Greece out of the you is is that
for Greece
is that for the EU so I wasn't in favor
of taking Greece out of the EU but
that's certainly a policy it has to do
its its forgiveness and it's got some
logic to it and many people thought that
showed blow the German Finance Minister
actually wanted to do that so it's a
sensible thing to think about but I'm
gonna argue tomorrow that I wouldn't do
that have done that yep can the Fed
forgive agency debt can the Fed forgive
agency debt well that's a complicated
question about whether the Fed can
forgive so which debt should have been
forgiven in is the question and I was in
favor of forgiving subprime debt that's
what I'm gonna argue tomorrow now why
subprime debt because those are the
people with the worst credit ratings
those are the people who are the most
underwater those are the people who are
gonna default anyway so you're gonna get
the least amount of money back for them
by throwing them out of their houses
they were the first to go and that was
the beginning of the crisis so I was
gonna argue that you should forgive
subprime debt of people who had kept up
all their payments in anticipation of
them defaulting you should forgive part
of their debts if they owed 160,000 the
house was only worth a hundred thousand
you should forgive it down to ninety
because you could see that eventually
they were gonna default and when they
defaulted you would get a terribly low
recovery so now who was gonna forgive
the debt I was going to make the lenders
forgive the debt so the lenders would be
so it wasn't the government who was
going to have to so most people think
debt forgiveness involves the government
holding the bag but the subprime
borrowers all borrowed from private
lenders hedge funds so it was the hedge
funds testifying in Congress that they
wanted to forgive the debt because they
could tell they would get more money
back in the end by forgiving the debt
than if the debt wasn't forgiven and it
wouldn't have cost the government
anything that's the argument I'm going
to make so the question about whether
the Fed
has the power to forgive the debt
without the Treasury I think that yeah
the Fed would have to involve the
Treasury in forgiving the debt and
potentially running a loss but I'm in
favor of debt forgiveness that makes the
lender more money that's one of the
conditions of forgiving the debt you
only do it when it's profitable to do it
and the crime and and the the tragedy is
that even when it would be more
profitable to forgive the debt we didn't
do it so so an answer to your question
if he thought that it was so I wouldn't
be in favor of the Fed or treasurer
together forgiving so much debt that
they would run huge losses I would be in
favor of doing in a way where they
wouldn't have to run huge losses yes I
noticed in one of your early graphs the
high ratio of debt to disposable income
in Scandinavia is there something
specifically Nordic about that
phenomenon you mean you know various uh
well early it's the same from Finland to
Norway yes there well I wouldn't say
it's specifically Nordic in fact Irving
Fisher you remember Shakespeare's
Shylock who gave the impatience theory
of interest in the Merchant of Venice he
anticipated Irving Fisher the guy I
mentioned from Yale who gave the modern
impatience theory of interest which is
that interest depends on how impatient
you are and he said the Nordic countries
are the most patient people they don't
want to borrow very much money because
they're so patient interest rates are
always lower in the Nordic countries
than in the southern countries it's the
Italians and the Greeks that are always
so prone to borrowing so I wouldn't say
that it was a Nordic malady that
explained that but it is true that a lot
of those Nordic could you know in
Ireland England they're all huge
loan-to-value so I'm not sure I could
attribute it like Irvin Fisher so
confidently to their ethnic origin but
it does seem curious that all those
countries up there at you
that Greece did not have high personal
debts
one last question back here John yeah
wonder if you could talk about the time
value of money and what it's doing to
people that are retired and gonna be
retired shortly the time value of money
you mean the low interest rates or well
one of the casualties of the low
interest rates that the Fed has been
holding now for years is that retired
people have lessen you know can't make
money on their savings so I'm not sure
you're getting at this but it raises a
question about where do we stand with
retirement programs in America like
Social Security and how badly off are
they and in fact why are they so badly
off so this story that arrow had with
the different time periods can be used
to understand Social Security so why do
you think Social Security is in trouble
why is it that it's running a deficit
now the usual answer is probably this is
what you think the people are living
longer now or that there was a baby boom
and all the baby boomers are retired or
that they're not enough children to pay
for the old people so those are the
usual explanations and of course there's
some truth to all of them there's
another explanation George Bush thought
that Social Security was just wasting
the money somehow
but but actually there's no program in
American history that's been so
efficient and so careful about keeping
track of all the finances I mean less
the expenses are less than 1% per dollar
contributed gets paid out a lot you know
it isn't paid out but it's paid to
people who work in Social Security my
father died and I remember thinking you
know I don't know who I'm supposed to
tell I don't know what's gonna happen
but but the the few weeks later his
Social Security check had already
stopped I mean they figure out things
that fast so this is they're not wasting
the money they've got a very efficient
so what is the reason Social Security's
in trouble
can anyone tell me what the reason is
what okay so here is something that you
might not have thought but if you did
that little reasoning with the different
time periods you realize it
Social Security began in the 1940s and
who it began 1938 and then 1940 Franklin
Roosevelt started it and what did he
decide to do he said people don't save
enough for their old age so we're gonna
start in America no one else had it
we're gonna start a Social Security
system where people are forced to
contribute when they're young and when
they're old they'll get paid the money
back and so we'll set aside the money
and put it in government bonds so that
was how it worked for two years and then
his his labor secretary Frances Perkins
first woman secretary said they're all
these old people now they need the money
right now they're starving look at
what's going on you've got all these
young people contributing the money's
just sitting there
let's give it to the old people and then
when the young people get old there'll
be more young people and they can take
the money from the new young people so
sounds like a good idea but and it
worked beautifully at the beginning it
solved the old-age problem in all the
destitution that was around during the
Depression of the ages but what actually
happened the people in 1940 who are
turning 65 who hadn't contributed
anything they were getting Social
Security but it's not just the people in
1940 the people in 1950 it only
contributed for ten years they were
getting their full Social Security the
people in 1960 who had only contributed
for twenty years they were getting their
full Social Security so for decade after
decade after decade we paid full Social
Security benefits to people who hadn't
made contributions or at least not
commensurate contributions so of course
all of them did beautifully they got
huge returns you compare someone you
know and then retiring in the 60s or 70s
compared there you know what they got
their old age payments to what they put
in they made a huge rate of return
but finally it had but what happened
money was going out it had to come from
somewhere
so it's future generations that had to
pay for it so the way to think of social
security is like if you've got a father
who has an operation and you have to pay
a million dollars to save them and you
do it then years later you know you're
getting old and you say to your son well
you're the grandson of I've saved your
grandfather and paid a million dollars
why don't you you know pay me a million
dollars now and so the grandson can pay
me a million dollars so I paid a million
I got a million back when I'm old and
then where is the loss well the losses
in the interest because the million that
I paid I got paid back a million later
but it was an a present value loss the
time value of money so what we paid when
we were young we didn't make up for when
we were old so Social Security this is
how we're paying for Social Security the
gift that we made to the original
generations in the 40s 50s and 60s that
gift is reenacted every generation so if
we were to stop paying Social Security
right now people like me who are about
to retire you know integrity Utley but
anyway when I'm about to retire it would
be me who wouldn't get paid or you we
would lose our Social Security payments
if we stopped Social Security
there's no all that money that got given
away can't be undone it's reenacted the
gift every generation so the amount that
was given away back then 40s 50s 60s and
today's dollars eighteen trillion
dollars that's where the social security
problem comes from we gave so much away
at the beginning
I'm not saying was a bad thing to do we
rescued all Volz elderly generations
that are on the brink of starvation but
we have to face up to the fact that we
made a gift and somebody has to pay for
the gift so every generation pays a
little bit of the gift that's why every
generation from now on is gonna get a
bad return on their Social Security we
would have seen this 20 years ago but we
had the baby boom which saved us
postponed the problems so many people
like me were contributing baby boom
generation but we didn't do anything
with those extra contributions we just
spent them we didn't save them now that
we're gonna have the baby boomers retire
gonna face that problem that we should
have faced 20 years ago and it's gonna
be bad returns for everybody so that's
the problem with Social Security it was
the gift we made to the original
generation by thinking a little bit in
these economic terms it becomes clearer
but if you don't think like that you'd
never guess that answer not one of you
thought of that even though that's the
real reason why social stick it's
inevitable in a pay-as-you-go system
okay well we'll see you all back here
tomorrow night thank you so much John